So I'm going to change a little bit because, I mean, I think the story of apomistumab is
actually something that is truly a lost opportunity.
And I'm hoping that I might even get some ideas of how we can resuscitate this and make
it the Lazarus of drugs.
So, you know, when we decided to study, we looked at where is the hardest challenge that
we as transplanters have.
And it's basically patients in which our leukemia colleagues have been unable to get
them in remission.
So patients with active disease have, you know, one, they're usually older.
They've already been treated with chemotherapy, so they've been beat up.
And, you know, not only do they have high non-relapse mortality rates, they generally
relapse and the outcomes are dismal.
So IMFB was developed by John Pagel at Seattle, and it's an anti-CD45 antibody that's
conjugated to radioactive iodine.
And it was dismal.
It was designed to develop very high doses of radiation to hematopoietic cells in the
marrow.
And in the Seattle studies, it was combined with a variety of conditioning regimens, but
they eventually decided to combine it with their backbone of fludarabine and low-dose
TBI.
So now, almost seven years ago, the group with IOMAB, we sat down and we said, OK, let's
how could we do a trial where we could go to the FDA and get a label?
And that's how the CRS trial was developed.
This is a prospective randomized phase three trial in patients over the age of 55 who had
active disease at the time of transplant.
And the primary endpoint was durable CR, which was a CR that was more than 180 days from
the first documented remission.
And we knew by retrospective that a person who had a remission that lasted more than
six months actually had a chance of being one year and two years in remission.
And the control group was a group of people who had a remission that lasted more than
And the control group was going to be physician choice.
So these were, you know, you could get a variety of chemotherapies, including intense or high
intense and low intense.
And if they achieved a remission, they would go to transplant.
So this was kind of the design.
This was, you know, we sat down with the FDA many times and the FDA agreed that if we achieve
the primary endpoint of durable CR, that would be, you know, reason for an indication.
So these were patients, again, with active disease, randomized one-to-one.
IMFB versus conventional care. And then if they achieve the conventional or complete remission,
the physician would decide whether they would continue chemotherapy or go to transplant.
IMFB, everybody got transplanted. Now, a trial like this is really difficult to accrue to
if you don't have a crossover design. Because who's going to want to put a patient with active
disease on conventional care when we know conventional care usually doesn't work? So
the crossover design was essential. And we calculated that there was going to be a 30%
crossover. So this was the administration. And one of the big pitfalls is we decided to put this
as a package. And I actually, when we started, I said, why don't we just say that transplantability
should be our primary endpoint. You give IMFB, and if you can transplant a patient three to four
weeks later, that's a success. And we, the FDA decided to know that we had to put it all as a
package. So we decided to put it as a package. And we decided to put it as a package. And we
decided to put it as a package. And we decided to put it as a package. So this is the concert. 163
patients were randomized, 76 to IMFB, 77 to conventional care. And one of the big notes is
we thought 30% were going to be crossover. 44 out of 77 patients, almost 50% crossed over to IMFB.
So this is just the bottom line. And I'm just, you know, the groups were, I just want you to
focus on how much disease these people had coming in. The average bone marrow
blast was around 30%. Many, 50% of these people actually had peripheral blood blasts, which
across all studies is the single most important predictor for per outcome. So these were really
bad patients. So, you know, we did the primary endpoint of durable, complete remission was
achieved. Most people with IMFB actually achieved a complete remission, but only 20% achieved a
complete remission. Look at the blue line is people who crossed over, right? The red line is people who were randomized,
IMFB in the, in the initial and the black line is people who never got transplanted. So, and there
was a significant benefit in one year survival for patients who got IMFB, who were randomized to IMFB
and for patients who got IMFB either as randomization or as crossover. The other
point to make is if you had a, we did, you know, again, demonstrate that if you had a six month
durable, complete remission, your chances of being alive at one year was around 70% in
remission and about, and in two years is around 60%. So you would durable, complete remission is
a valid endpoint for these people. Unfortunately, the FDA determined that the data from the phase
three Sierra trial is not adequate to support a biologic license application. And that the reason
they said that is that there was no survival benefit. Oops. Okay. That's the end of the story
here. What did I do?
Okay. Okay. I guess that was my, that was my, that was my, that was the, okay. That was the,
okay. Anyway. So, and the reason they gave us is, well, you couldn't separate the benefit of
APA-Mastema B from the benefit of getting transplanted. And when we said, well, wait a
minute, nobody got transplanted unless they got APA-Mastema B as part of their crossover. So,
you know, now doing the post-mortem here,
you know, the question is, is there a pathway for APA-Mastema B to be approved? The FDA said
that another phase three trial needs to be done. That's unlikely to happen. And, you know, we are
exploring to see whether with real world data, we could actually see if we can go back to the FDA
and say, look, looking at real world data, getting APA-Mastema B in the context of a reduced
intensity conditioning regimen should lead to approval. And it's, and I still have, you know,
long-term survivors have P53 mutations in the lesion 17, so we wouldn't expect them to do.
So, we really do think that this is a lost opportunity for this drug. And I want to thank
all of my co-investigators. This was published by Boglarka Gjogorca, who's now at Seattle,
and a whole group of Sierra investigators who really, you know, it was a work of love. We got
everybody accrued. These were hard patients to accrue to the study. But unfortunately,
we didn't pass the finish line. Thank you.
It was, there was no non-relapse mortality. It was really well tolerated. And initially,
the biggest barrier was the nurses didn't want to go into a room where people were quote-unquote
radioactive. But that was, you know, we finally got, we were able to accrue 163 patients.